foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing the darker side of the
Wizarding World diving deep into the
subject of horcruxes And discussing a
historical figure who created a horcrux
long before Voldemort ever did JK
Rowling once revealed that over the
course of history many witches and
wizards tried to create a horcrux in
spite of a severe lack of instructions
from Evil textbooks Wizards would have
been looking for ways to do exactly what
Voldemort did for years and some of the
ways they would have tried would have
killed them so I imagine it well they're
huge parallels splitting the atom would
be a very good parallel in our world I
do imagine that other people are going
to have tried I think it would be naive
not to think that people have been
trying for a long time and thought they
succeeded and hadn't or else maim
themselves or killed themselves in the
attempt it's such a dangerous thing to
do
what this quote tells me is that maybe
just maybe there's a wizard out there
that was able to produce a horcrux
before anyone else they just never made
it into the history books after all if
the idea of producing a horcrux is
self-preservation why would you want to
boast about it and bring it to
everyone's attention
I happen to have one very good guess for
who this wizard might be the original
horcrux Creator but first let's look at
the other Wizards in Harry Potter Canon
who are credited as having created
horcruxes and let's look at what exactly
a horcrux is a horcrux is a dark object
in which a dark Witcher wizard has
imbued part of their soul the ultimate
purse of creating a horcrux is to
achieve immortality JK Rowling who
coined the term defines it as follows a
receptacle prepared by dark magic in
which a dark wizard has intentionally
hidden a fragment of his soul for the
purpose of attaining immortality
according to Harry Potter Canon herpo
the fowl is the first wizard on record
to have created a horcrux
herpo was an ancient dark wizard that
hailed from Greece who happened to have
an awful lot of similarities to Salazar
sutherin he was a parcel mouth and he
created the first ever basilisk which
could perhaps suggest that Slytherin was
a descendant of her pose it's entirely
unknown when herpa walked the Earth but
we do know that it was a long long time
ago as he is commonly referred to as one
of the earliest known dark Wizards while
herpo is credited as having created the
first horcrux what's surprising is that
we actually don't know much about it we
don't know when he made it what it is or
if when it was destroyed
for all we know herpo could still be
around I've Got a Theory surrounding
this in another video The Lost horcrux
but go and watch that afterwards the
next credited horcrux Creator came along
many many centuries later a young boy by
the name of Tom Riddle Voldemort I would
venture to say that Voldemort is the
individual most commonly associated with
horcruxes not herpo despite herpo being
the first to create one and that's
because Voldemort whose main objective
in life was to achieve immortality
ultimately created seven of them a ring
diarrhea cup a locket a diadem a snake
and a boy so if not herpo and not
Voldemort who is this mysterious wizard
that I believe should be credited as the
first horcrux Creator if you're not up
to Snuff on your folklore particularly
your Russian folklore then the concept
of a soul container or Soul Shard like a
horcrux may have been introduced to you
in the Harry Potter books but as it so
happens this is not a novel concept and
it was actually introduced many many
centuries ago in folk tales now it's no
secret that JK Rowling tends to draw all
kinds of inspiration from all over the
map when doing her storytelling there's
Greek influence Roman influence historic
literary influence and well many other
kinds of influence evident within the
Harry Potter story and Rowling certainly
gives due credit to these sources of
inspiration however when questioned
specifically about the origin of
horcruxes JK Rowling claimed that
nothing in particular had inspired the
concept could this be the case certainly
but does this piece of Russian folklore
that I'm about to tell you seem quite
familiar you be the judge and let me
know in the comments the first folktale
containing a horcrux-esque object was
called zarovich Peter and The Wizard in
this story The tsar's Three Sons attempt
to rescue Tsar bellinin's wife these
aritza who has been abducted by a dark
wizard kosher
kosher who also goes by the epithet The
Immortal which Bears a striking
resemblance to Voldemort Voldemort
flight of death in French is an
archetypal male antagonist that has been
appearing in Slavic Tales since before
the 18th century in this tale two of the
tsar's sons fell in their attempts to
rescue these Ariza but the third son
Peter discovers the secret to kosher's
immortality koche much like Voldemort
discovered a dark spell that allowed him
to separate soul from body hiding his
soul inside of nested objects to
protected
the tale of crochet supports the idea in
Harry Potter that the soul is the most
important part of our life force and
that the physical body is merely a
container a vessel in order to prevent
himself from being killed nkoshay hides
his soul inside of nested objects in
order to protect it like the Russian
Matryoshka doll or nesting doll there
are layers and layers that need to be
peeled back in order to get to the base
layer each layer acting as one more
measure of protection
in kosher's tale his soul is hidden
within an egg within a duck within a
hair that nests in a hollow log that
floats on a pond found in a forest on
the island of bouyan in some versions
kosher's soul is hidden within a needle
within an egg within a duck with the
duck flying away whenever anyone tries
to catch It ultimately in the story of
Peter and kosher Peter is able to find
the egg and destroy him
some have speculated that crochet was
inspired by 12th century balotzsian
leader named Khan konchak kosher's
epithet The Immortal could potentially
be a reference to contract's longevity
as contract was able to live an
unusually long life despite it being the
12th century contract purportedly lived
for over 100 years which at the time
would have been the equivalent of many
generations though kosher's method of
Soul encasement differs from Harry
Potter in some ways it's hard to ignore
the parallels between crochet and
Voldemort and I for one thing that
kosher at least subconsciously if not
consciously inspired rolling's concept
of the horcrux both men created a
multitude of horcruxes by hiding
encasing Soul fragments into objects and
both of these men's objects happen to be
very difficult to find and provided that
kosher existed long before her put a
foul or Voldemort it's entirely possible
that he could be credited as the first
horcrux Creator even in the Harry Potter
Universe for all we know koche could be
related to the founders of the Russian
magical school called of stovoriettes
called
was apparently founded around the time
of the Novgorod Republic which checks
out time wise what do you guys think let
me know in the comments section below
until next time remember greatness
inspires Envy Envy engenders spite spite
spawns lies
[Music]
[Music]